I want the people to know that Africa is  on the ascendancy that there is  something to be optimistic about but  that we not right the assets that is  going to take a lot more of commitment  dedication and sacrifice to achieve  Africa's goal of development I want to  see for example that we have a  comprehensive and all inclusive growth  and development in Africa that we  empower the people the youth from the  cuddle that they have equal access to  education that the health fair system is  improved so that everybody has got  access to the health that Africa does  not just remain an exporter of raw  materials but that we add value to the  raw materials that we produce on the  continent and that we make good use of  the ICT for the benefit of our people I  think if we address those areas we are  likely to see fundamental changes in our  society